MARTYN POLIAKOFF:
I'm a chemist.
And therefore, I suppose the
most obvious number for me to
talk about is Avogadro's
number.
And Avogadro's number
is very big.
Surprisingly, although I'm a
chemist, I can never remember
the exact value.
So let me just look it up.
It is 6.02214--
and there's some argument for
further decimal places--
times 10 to the 23.
So this is a very,
very big number.
And it is related to atoms
and molecules.
So Avogadro was an Italian
chemist who worked at the
beginning of the 19th century.
And shortly after John Dalton
had proposed the idea of
atoms, Avogadro was thinking
of the number of atoms and
molecules inside a flask
a bit like this one.
So you imagine the
gas inside here.
From those ideas, he developed
the hypothesis about the
number of molecules of any
gas inside a flask.
But it's easier for me to
explain it to you with some
atoms here.
So imagine that we have here
hydrogen; carbon, which is
black; oxygen; and uranium,
which is big.
After the time of Avogadro,
people started measuring the
relative mass of these atoms.
So hydrogen has a mass 1, carbon
12, oxygen 16, and
uranium 238.
These are for particular
isotopes.
These weights are defined by
the number of protons, the
positively charged particles,
and neutrons, the neutral
ones, in the nucleus.
So for example, in carbon,
you have six
protons and six neutrons.
Whereas in uranium, you
have 92 protons.
And I can't work out the number
of neutrons, but they
add up to 238.
I'll leave that for
you to calculate.
Later chemists took Avogadro's
idea and developed it into the
statement that if you take 1
gram of hydrogen, 12 grams of
carbon, 16 grams of oxygen, or
238 grams of uranium, the
number of atoms in that sample
will be exactly the same.
And that number was given the
name Avogadro's number in
honor of Avogadro, who started
thinking about these things in
the first place.
BRADY HARAN: Professor,
is that fact a lovely
coincidence?
Or is that inevitable that
that would have happened
because of the way the weights
of atoms work?
MARTYN POLIAKOFF: This
is inevitable.
It's not a coincidence.
It's not just like the number
of my birthday, December the
16th, is the same as
the mass of oxygen.
It's something that's inevitably
true because of the
way that these mass scale
has been done.
It is the relative masses
of the different atoms.
The big question is, how can you
actually work out what the
number of these atoms are?
Because there's so
many of them.
You can easily say that even a
simple experiment that you
could do at school or college
will tell you it's 6
times 10 to the 23.
But it is the decimal points
and the numbers after the
decimal point that are
really the key.
And the more numbers you can
measure, the more precisely
you know the number.
Now, you can ask, what's the
point of measuring these
things so precisely?
Why do we want to know this
number so precisely?
And the reason is that it has
become very important in
recent years for the definition
of the unit of
mass, the kilogram.
As you know, we have a whole
series of fundamental units--
the second, the meter, and
so on, the ampere.
So you can define most of
these units, such as the
meter, in terms of the
speed of light.
But what do you use
for the kilogram?
Now, there's still
some argument.
But one approach is to say if
we could define Avogadro's
number, then we could relate
that to the mass of carbon-12
or whatever.
And then this would become
a fundamental constant.
And we would no longer have to
rely on a lump of platinum or
iridium stored in a vault
to define what
we mean by a kilogram.
The way that people are
approaching this is to measure
the mass of a lump of silicon.
The reason they've
chosen silicon is
because it is an easy--
or relatively easy-- material
to handle and purify.
So, they have made this
spherical lump.
Imagine now this is a real ball,
about the size of the
one I'm holding, but made
out of silicon.
And very special silicon,
the isotope silicon-28.
So that's just one isotope
of silicon.
And they have grown a single
crystal of silicon-28 and then
machined it into a
spherical ball.
And using this ball because you
can measure its diameter.
And you can measure, using
X-rays, the distance between
the layers of atoms.
You can calculate the number
of atoms in the ball.
You can't get the
nearest atom.
But all being well, they may be
able to get to 1 part in 10
to the minus 8.
That means, effectively, they
can measure the number or
calculate the number to nine
significant figures.
That's 6 point and then
eight numbers.
And each of those digits, they
can be certain, is right.
BRADY HARAN: Still a long way
off the whole number.
MARTYN POLIAKOFF: It's a long
way off, but it's near enough
to define the kilogram as
accurately as people want.
It might be worth giving you an
idea how big 6 times 10 to
the 23 really is.
And one of my friends, Colin
Johnson, has calculated--
and I haven't checked
his calculation--
that if you went round the
entire coast of the UK and on
every sandy beach used an
excavator to remove all the
sand to a depth of 1 meter.
And then you piled all that
sand up somewhere and then
counted the number of grains of
sand, it would be about 6
times 10 to the 23.
So if you took a lump of
gold just slightly
less than 197 grams--
which, because gold's dense, is
not very big, probably much
smaller than any of
these balls--
in that lump there would be the
same number of atoms as in
this huge pile of sand that
you've got from excavating all
the beaches to a depth
of 1 meter.
So you get the idea.
It's a big number.
The other thing is that most
chemists don't use Avogadro's
number very often.
But what they do use is the unit
that is called a mole.
And a mole is Avogadro's
number of molecules.
And they talk about reactions
very often in terms of moles.
Now, some of you may know that
in English, and American
English, mole is the name of a
small, furry creature that
burrows under the ground.
And in America, every year they
celebrate chemistry on
so-called Mole Day.
And they have all sorts of
cartoon moles that tries to
make people enthusiastic
about chemistry.
I appear on YouTube
quite frequently,
but not on this channel.
But on Brady's other channel,
the chemistry channel, called
Periodic Table of Videos.
And we have a lot of fans.
And last year, on Mole Day, a
fan in a school in Seattle
produced a mole.
She's called Melinda, and she's
in honors chemistry 3A.
BRADY HARAN: That's the
girl, not the mole.
MARTYN POLIAKOFF: Yes.
And she called this mole that
she made Moltyn Moliakoff.
And I think it's rather sweet.
And some of you who have a good
imagination may think
that there's a vague
resemblance between
the mole and me.
I think it's great that young
people, like Melinda, get so
enthusiastic about chemistry and
our channel that they make
models like this.
And I would encourage you, even
if you're a maths buff,
have a look at our chemistry
channel.
Because chemistry is more
fun than you think.
And it has bigger explosions
than on maths.
[EXPLOSION SOUND]
[LAUGHTER]
-Look at--
-I'm just going to check
that there's none left.